each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available okay well first of all I want
to say that I'm I'm really honored and
very thankful that we're having this
meeting in in honor of our colleague um
Dave notkin uh Dave was a real gentleman
he was an excellent researcher and a
wonderful mentor of students and a
wonderful um colleague to our to many
people in our profession including
myself so it's an honor for me to be
giving any kind of
presentation uh on his behalf basically
what try to do today is first I'm going
to look backward and remind us what
program analysis how we came to uh how
we use program analysis give a little h
history talk a little bit about this
Paradigm that we've been calling blend
analysis in our group for several years
now give you a taste for uh how it works
in the context of a blended information
flow problem and and then talk a little
bit about challenges that lie ahead for
program
analysis so uh in this audience some of
these beginning slides may be
unnecessary but I just want to make sure
we're all on the same page program
analysis uh historically uh compile time
or static program anal was developed to
be used in optimizing compilers and so
the idea was you had to understand the
potential behavior of a program and
ensure that you didn't change the
semantics of a program by any kind of
transformation that a compiler might do
and so you needed to give a safe
approximation of all possible behaviors
meaning you could return from an
analysis a larger set of behaviors than
the program had as long as all of its
actual execution behaviors were
contained in that set so that that's
what I mean by a safe
approximation uh and historically it
also was used for checking uh uh program
properties on the other hand Dynamic
analysis or profiling um was used by
many people to examine runtime Behavior
so static analysis was done with the
assumption that you you only looked at
code you didn't have any information
about execution time Behavior or
executions but Dynamic analysis was like
instrumentation it was tracking program
Behavior at runtime and you could
actually see things so in the software
engineering World static analyses were
used for VAR sorts of uh bug finding
programs or stylistic programs like lint
uh test cage generation and more
recently um uh tools like uhic testing
uh and and JV a Pathfinder to try to Jif
verify properties of programs and
dynamic program analysis used for test
coverage tools for debuggers and things
of that sort so the community the suffer
engineering community makes a great deal
of use of program analysis it's an
enabler kind of technology for Tool
building so let's not forget our history
lest we repeat it um these techniques
were really invented or or or designed
for languages like Forin okay pretty
simple procedural languages um first
they started out looking at code within
a function then they became into
procedural and dealt with uh programs
that were sets of functions or parameter
or procedures um things got more
interesting when we gave up copy in copy
out parameter passing which was pretty
simple to analyze and replaced it with
call by reference parameter passing
because then you had the possibility of
aliasing that is there could be more
than one name for the same memory
location to be accessed with within and
that understanding the code a little
difficult kind of like um memory
locations having pseudonyms if you will
okay and finally um people started
thinking about analyzing programs uh
subroutines on different or or
procedures on different invocations and
trying to specialize the analysis to the
parameters of
invocation trying to use calling context
to differentiate and make more precise
analyses we went forward into the 70s
and Heap Heap structures
Dynamic dynamically recursive uh data
structures and we ended points to
analysis and pointers and see which uh
made analysis great deal more difficult
uh and many many people including myself
published lots and lots of papers and
then lots of experiments with how to get
safe approximations of what a pointer
might point to at a particular point in
at a particular time in
execution onward into the mid um into
the 80s uh looking at languages like
Java and C++ I guess early 90s um now we
had object-oriented languages and there
was an interdepend dependency of data
flow and control flow because the type
of the object which was the receiver of
a method call determine the target
method chosen to be called and so no
longer could you think about um the flow
of data through a program is independent
of the calling structure of the program
and that made things a little more
interesting but B some of the work we
did in points to analysis could be used
in reference analysis we also had to
deal with um the introduction of
that is programs were allowed to ask
questions of State at runtime and base
execution on those answers at runtime
and so that introduces a kind of
behavior in programs that's very very
hard to analyze at compile time because
you have to take account of all the
possibilities uh for all the an possible
answers of the questions and finally we
ended up with many of the modern
scripting language um such as JavaScript
which is what we're going to talk about
today and these are languages that are
are really almost intrinsically dynamic
they have Dynamic typing not static
typing so objects can actually St change
their type during execution it's not
class-based inheritance it's Pro
prototype-based inher which is much
harder to model and they incorporate a
kind of a functional programming
construct where you can actually not
just load code dynamically from
somewhere else but you can actually
create code by
doing execution time and then
say this okay so this is sort of uh the
real um The Real Horror Story okay to a
compile time analysis is to try to
really figure this out at a at compile
time and in fact you can come up with
examples that are exceedingly hard if
not impossible so let's look at
JavaScript this is a little JavaScript
program it doesn't do anything
interesting it's up here so I can show
you what some of the dynamic aspects of
a Java of of features in JavaScript
actually are so we have this Fu function
and um the function is what we call a
vartic function meaning that it can be
called with a variable number of
arguments which affect its Behavior okay
uh and inside this function we actually
have an if statement where you can see
two very different uh type of objects
are created and the variable Z is made
to point to either one kind of object
that is created by a Constructor a or
another kind of object that is created
by a Constructor B and B two arguments
so we kind of figure out those are going
to be Properties or have something to do
with the properties of the object and a
gets one argument so clearly these are
going to be different
types and then down in the middle here
in the second if have a dynamic dispatch
but this is based on the type of of Z so
we're looking at the bar property of the
object that Z points to and since Z can
point to at least two different kinds of
objects we have no idea really what this
bar what this bar function is so we have
type based dispatch this looks Java it's
not okay and the thing that's different
is we can do an analysis at compile time
that does a pretty good job in a
language like Java or C++ or C sh
figuring out what kind of object Z can
point to because objects when they're
created don't change their type because
Java and C++ are strongly typed
languages this language isn't so the
object points to might be one of many
different types because the types can
change during execution more fun for
static analysis and finally this is the
kind of um uh evow statement that gives
uh headaches to people in static
analysis because prop three could be a
property that's some kind of um string
expression it could involve
concatenation of values that are input
it can involve concatenation of things
that are dynamically loaded excuse me
from another another website and without
very sophisticated string analysis it's
hard to figure out what's actually going
to be executed
there fortunately or unfortunately
JavaScript is a language and and it's
and its uh um uh its siblings I guess um
things like python things like Ruby
um th those kinds of languages are
actually being used quite a bit um as in
the bullets on the slide in real website
code and they're being used because
they're quite helpful to do the kinds of
operations and the kind of
based programming that that people want
to offer on websites and we have several
papers recently in the in the language
and the and the software engineer
community that attest to the fact
through Dynamic analysis that you can
see evidence of these kinds of of the
usage of the dynamic features so if we
want to be able to um enable maintenance
programmers to maintain this kind of we
have a program understanding problem if
we want to be able to test and have some
confidence of the coverage of our tests
on this kind of code AS software
Engineers if we want to try to figure
out that data inte the data Integrity
problem is actually um being addressed
those kinds of problems that we normally
do in software engineering in
object-oriented languages are rendered
more difficult in these of languages
because of their dynamism because of
these Dynamic properties okay so what
answer well um one answer that we're
trying is to um reject the idea that we
have to do everything in a safe static
Anis Manner and try to combine Dynamic
analysis with static analysis in a way
that enables us to capture more of the
dynamic behavior of these programs save
it and then analyze standard static
analysis that portion of the program
that we have actually exercised okay so
that's the the main idea so Blended
analysis is a way to tightly couple an
initial D dyamic analysis which is very
lightweight and only records uh in the
problems we've been looking at um method
calls and object creations and to take
those pieces of information and
formulate a call graph that's annotated
with that information and then consider
applying a static analysis for your
favorite problem uh points to or
whatever you want to do uh side effect
analysis on that portion of the program
so it's not a safe call graph it's
doesn't cover all the calls in the
program we're just looking at some set
of executions we've observed so what are
the positive things about this well
first of all we see all the code it's
dynamically created or dynamically
loaded or it was statically visible
program we have a dynamic analysis that
collects the code at runtime and
secondly we're actually able to do some
pruning that is within some methods
we're able to try to specialize them for
the parts actually were executed during
this execution and if the executions are
problematic if they're Associated for
example um with a performance that
problem that we don't really understand
then we don't care about the other
behaviors we just want to concentrate on
the behaviors on this set of execution
and so that gives us some a leg up as it
were in terms of being able to be less
approximate by the second phase of
static analysis and it also allows us to
to deal with Dynamic Pro constructs and
so I want to show you some beginning
work that we've done uh that we is very
promising in terms of how we can deal
with these constructs so first I'm going
to show you a picture of um a framework
that we've built and it's a
plug-and-play kind of framework so you
can take your favorite static analysis
and put it into the static analysis uh
module here and then I'll show you how
we've instantiated it for the um taint
analysis problem which is a information
flow problem so here we have uh a
javascrip program and we have a um a
dynamic phase that is dynamic analysis
phase the execution collector is a piece
of the program uh you can think of it as
we're testing a website and we run the
test suite and we keep we do this
lightweight Dynamic analysis and collect
the calls that happen on for each test
and what what objects are created and
where and so we generate a set of traces
and we send it to a trace selector the
job of the trace selector is basically
to say well maybe we don't want to
statically analyze the entire test the
results of the entire test Suite maybe
there's some redundancy in there maybe
we want to pick out a subset and then
try to static an Analyze That subset and
save us a little
time
okay the second phase of the analysis
given some selected set of traces is a
big block I call static infrastructure
and I'll put more clothes on these
basically the building of the program
representation from the traces and the
walking of the program representation to
do a standard compile time analysis
happens here on each trace and then we
send the over to a a solution integrated
because we're looking at pieces of the
program as we see them on these
executions we've collected so we need
an uh
module I think of it as a gigantic
generalized Union to kind of combine
together into a total solution for the
program for the part of the program we
explored so again this give us the same
thing as a safe static analysis we're
hoping it'll give us something more
practical and something that will be uh
more precise on the languages because
we're able to um observe some of the
dynamic exec all of the dynamic
execution on these test cases so that's
the overall put together of the
framework now let me put some close on
it in terms of how we do this for taint
analysis of websites so we have a
website tester and she is exploring the
website by clicking on various um URLs
and various uh uh actions and buttons
and we actually using a modified version
of safari that Yan Vitex group at Purdue
put together and we changed some of the
parameters to collect a few different
things and so we collect um all the
they're being executed whether they're
dynamically created or generated or not
and then we feed them into our Trace
selector okay and I don't want to go
into detail but we have a urtic
basically that tries to make sure we
cover as many Dynamic constructs as
possible as many methods as possible and
as many kinds of objects that were
created as possible in the program and
so we collect the set of subset of
traces that will allow us to get that
kind of
coverage and then we basically collect
code from these Trac for each Trace we
collect the code that we saw was
executed we build a call graph and then
we
enter vanilla static as you would apply
GL globally if you did this all as a
static
problem so to put a few more clothes on
this let me show
you here is the this is the dynamic
trace and basically when you're website
you do some stuff on one page then if
jumps you to another page and then it
jumps back to the first page and so
forth so we have a trace with sub pieces
from each
page each one of these subpage P pieces
to us is what I'm going to call a page
trace and it consists of a calling tree
uh which are which is the tree of method
calls that happened on that page the
dynamic code that we collect that was
generated or loaded as well as the
static code on that page and the object
creation sites that we saw executed
while that page was was uh executed so
we take traces of this kind these page
traces put them through the selector and
out comes set of traces we're going to
analyze okay then the static
infrastructure consists of these two
pieces we come in through the static
infrastructure for each each page Trace
right for each page Trace we take the co
tree and build a CO graph we take the
dynamic and static code we collected we
do a step called pruning that I'll show
you in a minute the pruning that is
specializing code inside the method to
this particular trace and then what
comes out is the code for that method
we're going to an okay and we do this
piece over here for each one of the
circles or functions that we're showing
in the in the co graph so here's code
pruny so here's a really simple kind of
diagrammatic um uh control flow graph
the flow of uh the flow inside of a
method we have two potential allocations
and two potential calls and the
information at the top tells me that we
only observed allocation one and call
one so what that means is that
allocation two didn't happen during this
page trace and what that means is we can
get rid of that node and any nodes that
are control dependent on the same
conditions as that one and likewise we
can get rid of the calls that didn't
happen and any nodes that are have the
same control dependence conditions so
alt together the stuff at the top is I
just showed you what happened in the
code pruning piece and then we go
through a static taint
analysis and rather than detail about
this because I see I'm a little short I
want to show you results as well
basically the new stuff here is it's a d
it's a plain vanilla points to analysis
but we use the dynamic call graph we
observe
not an on the-fly created static call
graph those of you that know points to
know that you're doing points to and
have construction together this just
says that we're doing a taint problem
meaning there's some user inputs with
which are the sources and we're trying
to see whether there's some path in the
program we can make it to between the
sources and the sync which is some kind
of um sensitive function call that we
don't want this input data to be able to
reach because a malicious person or
malicious uh unit might might send band
dat there this is just an optimization
we don't have to talk about this and
this is plain vanilla Tain propagation
on the as you would do if you did a
totally static
thing so we put together an experiment
initial experiment to try to look at um
pure static analysis Straw Men that we
put together uh and our blend analysis
so static an static taint plus uh looks
at the application code and the library
code of these of these websites static
taint minus just looks at the
application code now what we used for
the points to analysis was the best
analysis that is a that was available
which was a correlation points to done
by uh the group at IBM and to Walla
which is their analysis framework it was
uh talked about at E coupe 12 so all
these analyses use that points to
analysis the difference is the static
analyses use a static call graph our
Blended analysis use the uses the
dynamic call graph that we built from
observations and we tested these two
hypoth hypothesis okay how do these
approaches differ in accuracy and how do
they how long do they take to do their
analysis so had um an undergraduate
student sit and exercise uh 12 of the
top 25 websites at Alexa uh when this
work was done uh she didn't know
anything about the JavaScript code so we
thought that this is sort of a blind
test generating test cases uh this is
the number of pages we actually had from
each website that we exercised and this
is the number of traces because each
Trace is subdivided into sub pieces that
explore pages and these are the results
that we got in terms of accuracy so you
can see that the Blended taint analysis
I mean first of all this is a sparse
problem it's it's a it's a security
problem we don't expect to find you know
tons of answers so um only six of the 12
websites uh actually correspond we
actually found uh possible
vulnerabilities in the Blended taint the
blue part is good high is good here it
means we found some some source to syncs
uh potential problems and and the red
part shows the false positives so the
true the true positives were actually
checked by hand and true and false
positives and the blend and taint did a
lot better than either of the two static
tanks and in fact found seven more um
true positives
four of them were in the dynamic code in
the code that the static analysis just
couldn't see couldn't deal with three of
them were we don't know because three of
them were in the static part of the code
but we set a limit like our um points to
analysis uh Creator colleagues did 10
minutes was considered too long okay so
it was a 10-minute limit if the points
to analysis took more than 10 minute it
failed and we just didn't analyze that
page okay so that was our our level of
scalability which was borrowed from our
colleag Coles uh so we posit that the
three that we that the static analyses
didn't find but were in the static code
potentially if we let it run long enough
they might have found it okay they
should have found it because they're
both well at least the plus one that
does whole program analysis should have
found it the minus one which forgets
about libraries there's a possibility it
wouldn't
have so here blender found all true
positives additional seven reported one
false positive and reported no false
positives from the observe code and this
is maybe the more interesting result
which is the Blended finished analyzing
everything and in fact did it on average
in less than 60 seconds the static taint
plus look at this timed out at almost
half of the pages it would that was the
whole point analysis and static analysis
timed out at the 10-minute point of over
half the pages and so here blue means
that Pages were analyzed and red means
the percentage of the pages that weren't
this is a scalability result we
feel okay no free lunch so what what am
I hiding you know this is great what am
I hiding
well this is a security problem right
and so um and and this is an unsafe
analysis so let me just dwell a little
bit on analysis Theory here I'm going to
try Asal as possible the the ellipse on
the on the left this is it this is this
represents the solution that some pure
static analysis would find the ellipse
on the right represents the solution
that our Blended analysis would find
part in the middle here is the part of
the solution found by both could have
false positives could have true
positives the part label number one
represents part of the solution that may
be Blended misses because we didn't
explore the parts of the program that
resulted in this in these exploits so if
we get good coverage I mean this is our
hypothesis if we get good enough
coverage of the paths in the program
we'll make one as small as possible
possible and we're trying for good
coverage of the um the the calling
structure in the program part number two
and we observe this in our experiments
are the parts of the solution that lie
in the dynamically generated or loaded
code that static analysis cannot deal
with okay so static analysis cannot get
this and so what we are settling for
what we are suggesting is that it's
better to have a practical approach that
will find you exploits in the Dynamic
code that static really can't deal well
with and in most of the rest of the
program knowing that you're using an
unsafe tool so you're there's no
guarantees associated with it but it's
better to do this in a practical tool
than potentially to get so many false
positives and and and and or even time
out after very long execution times in a
pure static analysis and that for those
of you who know my career this may sound
like heresy because of the way I started
with my first paper being in pole but
I'm this this is the Future these are
the kind languages people are using now
and this is what we're going to have to
do so we feel that we proved that both
of hypothesis are true that we have an
officient algorithm it handles Dynamic
features at least the ones that we put
in t uh it's scalable to Real World
website and in future of course we
haven't really totally dealt with the
dynamic typing we'd like to make our
analysis more precise and be able to
Tech object types change and maybe
change our answers um in response to
that and so um and we also feel that it
to know what family of other Dynamic
languages like these script like like
JavaScript that are very very helpful in
in programming today we could apply
these ideas to and we feel that there's
a lot anality here and I've totally run
out of time so I'll just put this up
these were my attempt to to try to think
about future questions I still think
it's hard to deal multi language systems
multi-paradigm systems nobody really has
a handle on this and this is probably as
an educator I think this is probably
most important question what are about
parallelism we bemoon the fact that
we're not teaching our students well
enough how to use the four cores that
are inside things like this or the
things in our pockets and I don't think
that the analysis Community dynamic or
static has really up with you know how
we're going to deal with this kind of
programming and this is going to be the
kind of programming that everyone is
going to do so that's the future there's
more to do questions that is a hokey
bird
thank
you Danny so I'm not surprised that your
blend analysis did so well I'm surprised
that the static I was expecting that the
number of the red the number of f even
actually way much higher so I'm
surprised that it did so well knowing
how many unknown points and how
many well these are the most popular
websites these are not I'm not we're not
suggesting these are programs that you
know that the creators have not looked
at and when you look at these security
pro problems you don't find it's not
like looking for bugs you don't find
scads and scads of instances of these
security problems so I think that
explains
why uh exploits and not that many false
positives but each of the static methods
had almost half of what they reported as
false positive which as we all know if
you get half the you know that large a
false positive rate people lose
incentive to use your tool to use your
analysis you find exploits in the
libraries like jaky and all these other
these were just in user code what we
reported here was just in user code we
looked at the library but we didn't we
didn't we didn't go we didn't look for
exploits in the sources were not in the
in the library oh the
sinks
yes I can see how this is
incred like vartic functions and things
like that well we okay I had i i i s
some stuff what we do with the vartic
functions we is we introduce a Ty a type
of um context sensitivity and so
basically every time you have a
invocation of a function that has a
different number of parameters or
different types we we spew another node
in the call graph so we're basically
effectively by copying making it kind of
embarrassingly context sensitive if you
will so so very out of code yes but
there are some other I mean as I said we
haven't dealt explicitly with the
dynamic types uh the points to analysis
we actually have another work now that
in it's in submission but in the work
I'm reporting here the points to
analysis was Aggregate and there was one
points to graph for the whole P you know
for the whole page for the whole program
so we think of a JavaScript page that's
explored by several of these page traces
put together for the same page as a
JavaScript
program yes is that relationship with TR
Jus in time compilers TR oh okay
uh I don't know um the the the
trace-based compilers are looking for
optimization opportunities I think not
looking for so so I believe that if they
if they translate code they have to also
keep the code semantically equivalent
but they're looking for optimization
opportunities so if they get it wrong
they just optimize something that's not
executed very much what I'm doing here
is really missing some of the code
potentially so I I think I think there's
a philosophical difference there for
compiler uh for translation this is not
appropriate but for some problems that
are program property questions this
might be
appropriate does that answer your
question
yeah
three essentially it seems that that
would be an open because you
know
inut from the user and did you in your
experiment did you see convergence in
this set like you
know more
experiment what what no what three was
was the part that Blended the part
that's in the dynamically created part
of the program that Blended can capture
but static can't we can only answer that
question with regard to the state of the
program at one time if the program
changes then that picture would change I
mean you know did you observe that after
so many time ex exting the software this
set is converging because this set would
grow if
just take this line well we'll need to
use pencil and
paper yeah let's go ahead and switch and
we'll have a a discussion after this
talk so encourage you to bring those up
cool
stuff can you all hear
me okay so next present is going from
and he's going to be talking about this
is not on oops you can't hear me it's
first time that's ever happened our next
speaker is Bill shus uh from Carnegie
melon University and he's going to be
talking today about software Assurance
particularly I believe focusing on
scalability and making sure and software
Insurance works on really large systems
not just toy examples good thank you uh
it's very pleased to be here it's um uh
and especially to speak with you about
software assurance and so since I'm
speaking about software assurance
it makes sense to start
with the Queen of
England um this is a natural starting
point and why is
that and so here's here's a hint is it
about software or about insurance it's
about software and Assurance okay so
here's my hint what do all these three
things have in
common come on
now Tony Tony thank you very much
Tony who who was knighted by the
queen first computer scientist to be
kned by the queen and so some time ago
at a meeting at the hcss meeting sir
Tony made a comment to me we treat our
software as a phenomenon of Nature and I
start with this because it carries two
important messages about software one is
that like other mysteries of nature we
will never fully understand it and we
will never fully control it so these are
really challenges of complexity and
predictability um and this is a kind of
a curious State of Affairs given the
reality of software which is it we
create the languages the compilers and
other infr in which it's written right
and we build the computers on which it
runs but we still don't understand it
and so herb Simon phrase The Sciences of
the artificial also applies here um and
evokes this now there's some virgent
complexity and for but for larger
systems I think it's fair to say that
that's a relatively small part so the
fundamental question for soft insurance
is whether this is somehow an immutable
truth that we will not make progress or
perhaps there's something that we can
change so I want to get past the sort of
the reductive conclusion of well yes
both um and and make an assertion today
that we can intervene over time to
undermine the validity of Tony's
assertion okay and in fact make solid
progress the reality is that the
software Assurance problem is getting
both harder and easier um and I want to
emphasize both and Barbara's talk
actually is the perfect lead in because
it is harder because we are inventing
these languages and getting ourselves
into pickles that we maybe don't need to
be in but here we are so I'm going to
spend a few minutes trying to talk you
into taking an optimistic istic attitude
on this uh that it is getting easier
more quickly than it's getting
harder okay so here's the overall
structure of my story um and it kind of
boils down to how we can think as a
community uh about how we might proceed
now those of you who've been around for
a long time know that there are many
dark lessons from the past um those of
you who remember in particular the 70s
and 80s uh are probably the most most
Ardent Skeptics uh and pessimists in the
room and I was involved in working on
theor provs and verifiers back then and
remember it well but I would also say
like much of what we do in computer
science it's not so much what's new it's
what's timely and I think there are a
lot of ideas now that that are timely
that we can take
up okay and so in particular uh we're
seeing some benefits now from some new
uh and I think really important
technical interventions and we're also
seeing evidence actually of a strong
business case or at least a kind of an
internal uh business case in which
informed management has made a judgment
to continue with the campaign of pushing
forward with a
rions uh related to software assurance
and I'm particularly glad to be here at
Microsoft to talk about this because
they're way out ahead in both of these
respects both with respect to the
technical interventions and also with
respect to uh that um uh case strong
case for internal adoption they they
actually really do it um and so let's
start with the harder part of the story
uh this is kind of a of a road map for
our conversation we all know that that
software is getting more capable in its
function it's more dominant as an
engineering material uh it's more
critical or comp more critical in its
role and it's also more complex in its
structure and in fact uh the National
Academy economists that's what the step
committee is said that software may be
and this was 2006 the single largest
asset type uh in in the economy people
who are involved uh with the F-35
estimate that maybe 90% of its
functional features are manifest in
software in one way or another um
software with wings is a phrase that was
coined more than 15 years ago actually
uh in vehicles we're seeing a similar
situation the number quoted from
industry is about 50% and we also know
that software is doing a lot more than
manifesting capability it's also a locus
of
flexibility the software goes up into
space after the satellite is already
launched um and it's also a mechanism
for linking things together so uh but we
also know that that the technical
influences advances in software have had
a a big influence architecture matters
tools matter process matters and
language actually does matter quite a
bit and uh both in positive ways
and uh Barbara thank you for reminding
us of the negative ways that language
matters so um all this uh these
technical advances and it's very
important to recognize the role of the
technical advances they enable this kind
of worldwide development that we see for
example with with Linux the this is the
geography of Linux developers around
around the world um but more
importantly they have these rich
Frameworks apis Rich Supply chains for
software years ago we didn't have such
Rich Supply chains so if we look at
infrastructure users not so much
Microsoft but if we look at financial
services and healthc care and everybody
else actually this tremendous complexity
um and we've also gone and this is a
very important Point Butler Lamson years
ago said about reuse well we do it it's
just a giantz components operating
systems and databases we've actually uh
gone down now to much more granular
reuse and therefore within our systems
we have these steeper gradients of trust
which means that our problem is getting
more significant we have attack surfaces
within the systems um not just around
the
systems and this is you know
particularly challenging for the
infrastructure uh
users okay so um so these rich
architectures and are it's really
important to understand this they're
fundamentally compelling for developers
so an undergraduate building an app a
mobile app can go from a gleam in the
eye to an app in the app store in a
matter of
weeks okay that's the advance of our
technology or if you just write a few
hundred lines of code of map functions
and reduced functions you can go out and
do large and a few really nasty command
lines you can go out and do large scale
data analytics um and the EOS build on
other advances and so anybody know what
the significance of this picture might
be
I'll give you a hint
Zeus so this is Athena bursting from the
head of Zeus which is how people think
the iPod and iPhone burst from the head
of Steve Jobs but since Rick Rashid is
being honored uh and and returning to
his work in operating systems The Mach
OS is in there in the iOS world uh it's
important to remember the the Heritage
and and the the the richness of of the
infrastructure it's so now let me switch
over to the easier part of the story and
consider the broad time scale going back
to when I first met David notkin in fact
uh when he was a a PhD student Nico
harman's PhD student um at at CMU in the
bad old days of of
verification um and the easier story
really has two related Dimensions one is
the technical
advancment related to uh a range of
technical advancements but particularly
influencing our ability to scale up
and the second uh area of this easier
part of the story has to do with process
realism and Tool advancement I'm going
to start with process realism and Tool
advancement because this is in some way
the biggest shift from the 1970s you
know it in the 1970s people people who
were thinking about formal reasoning
looked at the waterfall chart and said
well here's verification right after
coding and specification was done back
there so we'll after the code is written
in the specification is written and
we'll fill in that box with something
that does something
automatically and that just was never
going to work okay and the other thing
about the focus in that time was on
functional features of the system and
pretty much all the analysis we've been
talking about here and and in related
meetings to a great extent really
focuses on quality attributes and there
are huge number of quality attributes so
with respect to this process realism and
Tool advancement there are
four facets that I want to talk about so
here's one of them which is we're
getting a lot better at advancing
quality interventions earlier in the
process the whole point if you look at
the libner Howard sdl for example um or
the Bim framework for evaluation of sdl
like implementations that Gary McGraw
and his buddies cooked up you see that
there's a strong pressure to move points
of evaluation as close as possible to
the point of action that
uh might cause the evaluation to be
meaningful and so this is NASA's version
of the chart that you've all seen in
many forms of how much more it costs as
a function of how late you find the bug
right okay and unit testing we've got
type checking we've got builds and this
influences quite dramatically the
economics of overall cost okay so a
second Point here is
that um thanks to the tools we we've
gotten a lot better at what I'm going to
call incremental models and this is a
really important point that kind of has
to do with economics of costs benefits
but also uh
uncertainty okay and the idea of the
incremental model is an an increment of
investment yields an increment of return
and right
away okay this is important because our
processes tend to be iterative and so in
the iterations we reduce uncertainty we
uh uh that's key feature of of the
iterative process so in a sense it has
two pieces one is that we can take small
actions and get benefits for those small
actions and two the time from action to
benefit is short right so the old model
is I make a big investment of writing a
lot of assertions covering my program
with invariance and pre- and post
conditions and then maybe later I'll get
some benefit for that the new model is
my action is a line or two of test of
text and then I get something for that
so I'm going to show you this little
quote from The Chronicle of Higher Ed
I'm sure all you read this
thing okay and this was written by an
English Professor observing about
computer science students as compared
with English students the English
students felt that they needed to write
the essay and get it right right away
and then submit it and it would be
perfect but not and the computer science
she was observing uh in a sort of a
jealous attitude was they don't mind
failing they keep iterating and they
keep failing they do it all the time
it's built into the process and they
take it in stride and it's not that
we've somehow have become habituated to
to
failing
rather we're really iterating we're not
failing so much as we're making
increment progress of a certain kind we
get increments of validation for our
actions we reduce the cone of
uncertainty there are lots of little
benefits with respect to either the
meantime to complete or the variance
with respect to getting to completion
that's what happens in these iterations
and so we want to do the same thing with
software Assurance in our process we
want to get the Assurance related
activities Advanced as much as possible
integrated as much as possible so a
third Point here about process realism
is that our activities our processes are
now tightly integrated with tools IDE
type tools for Developers team type
tools we have now a data intensive
reality in software engineering and we
need to exploit that again for folks
who've been around for a long time we're
used to this impoverishment of data now
we have masses of it and we can do
really great things to integrate all the
various features this is a tremendous in
increase in automation so this is all
from Mozilla because I can show it to
you but all the commercial systems kind
of do this every line of code millions
of lines of code its Heritage is out
there to be seen
every little increment of change is
accounted for we've got extremely
granular Communications and interaction
about issues uh we without
specifications we don't know if they're
bug or feature requests and we have this
infrastructure for builds and tests
analysis if I click on one of these
links I get performance test there's
lots of stuff going I analysis all this
cool stuff okay and even some is a pitch
for what I'm working on with which is a
sound static analysis to support anal
reasoning about locks in Java programs
uh but there are a lot of examples of
that okay so um with respect to these
tools Watts Humphrey who was the
advocate of and a staunch advocate of
process for many years he was in the
Edgar dyst School of paper so I don't
know how many of you read those old
Edgar Dy sces but the originals were all
handwritten okay and even Dana Scott his
his papers were largely handwritten and
discovered Tech and then then of course
transformation but in his later days
Watts actually recognized that for small
teams there's simply no way for the
economics of developer time and
attention to do the work without tooling
it's
essential okay and so finally we can
apply this uh incremental model to the
space of quality attributes and so this
is the cwe whether you like it or not
it's say inventory it's got all kinds of
category problems and the like just
throw it at you as an example of the
huge array of different kinds of quality
attributes and here's a tiny I've just
picked a few because I like concurrency
there's some concurrency my point is
that if we can get granular with respect
to these quality attributes we have a
greater chance of making progress okay
don't think about the whole thing as as
is it good or is it not but rather think
about uh sort of disaggregating quality
into a composite think of it as a
composite of a set of uh more more
smaller attributes and we wait the
elements according to the context of
use okay so then and here's some other
examples of attributes which are kind of
difficult to assure using traditional
means of testing and inspection these
are kind of the the natural targets for
the kinds of analyses that that Barbara
is talking about and that are uh very
much the focus of a lot of the tooling
that's being developed at at at
Microsoft
okay okay so
so I I want to uh talk now about so I've
talked about process realism now I'm
going to talk about some technical
advances uh uh related to analysis and
and composition I'm using analysis in a
in a very broad sense and the the key
Point here this is by the way a little
puzzle for you while I'm talking if you
don't want to listen to me talk fast um
find the
bug this was in Mathematica for years
undetected in binary
search and if you know John Bentley did
a study many years ago he got all those
hardcore uh AT&T Developers for the
switches and he said I got an exercise
for you here's two hours here's a blank
sheet of paper write binary search and
they said
WTF can do this like that go out and
have coffee and nearly all of them were
wrong canth did a study for the first 16
years there was not a single correct
version of binary search published in
the literature so even something very
small like this is hard to get right
okay back to my point all right so
so some of the most important advances
that we have made related to this broad
notion of analysis have to do with
composability if you can't compose you
can't get to
scale that's just the the iron law of
our world and so if you look at typing
systems you see that we have pulled it
off for typing systems but we are also
increasingly pulling it off for many of
those little attributes in that diverse
array of attributes this is a reason for
optimism but it's also a reason to keep
working hard because it's not easy to
get to that state of having composable
analyses okay ideally and soundness is
important we want let me get past this
um we we want uh uh wise composability
important by the way if you go back to
this these rich Supply chains all of
these involve various bits of code the
granular business of providing little
components the glowing button that you
want to put into the guey that you pull
off the inter internet that little file
you want to build that into your system
well you need to be
confident uh that that little component
doesn't have extra functionality that's
the attack surface within so uh we we in
order to get to where we want to be with
this we actually have to accept some
notion of fragmentary
specification and I would say Microsoft
actually has pioneered this but there
are other examples I mean the the use of
of J m l uh Tom Ball gave a talk
recently about typescript um the point
of providing these little fragments of
specification fundamental to getting to
the point Beyond heuristic and into
actual soundness no false
negatives okay and and so my students
for example when they work on the a
notion ofation density uh a metric of
how much annotation do I have to write
in order to get a certain theorem proved
about the systems so so there are a lot
of examples of technical uh advances
here that many of you are responsible
for for example things like like type
States and and permissions um and and
you know concurrency attributes and the
like and this enables these very rich
apis the kind of apis that let those
apps get
written um uh and to actually get some
analyses targeted at those apis so you
can keep getting more expressive and
more rich apis but analyses that go with
them so that you can be more confident
that you're actually uh complying with
the rules of the
road okay so I have to make a brief
comment and I'm sorry to inflict this on
you but about evaluation standards um
and and you know I uh I was at DARPA for
seven years get used to briefing
fast um and you know that was 20 years
ago
but with the dod it's like the hotel
California you can check out but you can
never leave and so I keep thinking about
these issues for them and and I have to
comment therefore on the sorry state of
the situation of evaluation standards um
uh relating to software Assurance
because I mean there's a lyy of woes
here that I can talk about I'll just m
name a few one is they generally presume
a linear
process um
and uh they generally do an evaluation
after the fact that old verification
model you know you finish the thing you
deliver it off to an evaluator and maybe
a year will go by and a lot of money
will be spent before you get any result
and that evaluation process entails
enormous amounts of reverse
engineering the information loss is
prodigious think about these
things
okay and it cannot support things that
we take for granted in the modern world
of agile and devops continuous Evolution
changes of configuration Dynam Dynamic
changes of configuration component based
architecture Dynamic architecture
adaptive and resilient architecture okay
and it's not informed also by the kinds
of modern techniques that we have for
specification and
Analysis okay so um so I mean there's
some excuses for this I mean good
reasons for this situation one is that
these standards take years to ratify and
get in place there are just hideous
consensus processes that have to go on
in order to get for example to an ISO
standard they take a long time so you
want timelessness and therefore you're
going to get disconnected from the
technology and therefore you're going to
get process focused and you get to get
pulled away from the actual
artifact and it's the code that executes
that matters now you say well think
about the old orange book A1 if you
remember that one formal verification
but what's the formal verification of
it's of properties of the
specification that doesn't actually
sufficient the code so fortunately
there's now a very strong message from
the users saying that this state of
affairs cannot continue this is a great
opportunity for the research Community
it's a huge opportunity the National
Defense authorization act actually has a
section in there you can look it up 933
which says you guys got to get your act
together on software
Assurance so the real deal they really
recognize it in 2017 the defense science
board issued a report saying oh these uh
the attack surfaces are within
gosh finally figured it out that's great
and failure to maintain a lead in the
ability to prevent and evaluate confers
advantaged adversaries all of this is a
strong signal nard which is the
coordinating entity for all the federal
agencies has a whole theme called
designed in security it's exactly about
this
stuff okay
so got to calm down after that so we we
have to kind of figure out how we can
work within realistic guidance I mean
the sdl is really Baseline um and and
and try to how within that framework to
get a little bit more product focused a
little bit more directly evaluating of
the artifact and and the success of AR
here at Microsoft the challenge is how
do we make that sort of more extensible
and repeatable um and build it into the
expected pervasive Baseline of best
practice all right now I have add one
point about software just to reinforce
the need here okay to address this
carefully and that is the most important
point we are not getting to a plateau in
capability many of you remember there
was a Harvard Business Review paper that
came out about a decade or so ago it
said with respect to Enterprise it we
have Erp SCM and CRM ask me later what
they mean and now we're
done for the Enterprise for it search
for S sources of productivity value
elsewhere than it okay and what happened
since then Cloud mobile ecosystems
machine learning Big Data analysis and
so on and so on okay we we just we're
not going to get to a point of
automating programming now I I put this
slide in the deck uh because somebody
earlier was talking about getting rid of
programmers through clever automation
this is a paper from 1958 by John bachus
of the first one of the first Fortran
compilers automatic programming okay now
he wasn't basically he was not saying we
don't need no stinking programmers that
was not the point that was the term of
art at the time but the idea of
automating programming keeps coming back
4g's similar assertions were made the AI
crowd did it in the 70s and early 80s
and and the point is the tide of
abstraction just continues to rise and
there's no bound on that and that's one
of the reasons why our problem is both
hard getting harder and getting easier
because we just keep getting expressive
and so this coming from Pittsburgh have
to show you a sort of a Ste kind of a
shot because it's not like steel it's
not going to hit some sort of ASM toote
as a commodity Commodities sort of have
these ASM tootes we don't have any ASM
toote in sight so we have the chance if
I go back to the very beginning of my
talk right whereas we control language
we control the infrastructure we can
just just Vector those things just a
little bit it looks like it's Dynamic it
looks like it's doing eval but maybe
really not maybe we can actually have
some analysis behind behind the scenes
and we can keep moving in that direction
and maybe I'm being ridiculously
optimistic okay so I have a modest
proposal um and I'm uh uh I just want to
toss this out at you and and the idea is
kind of very simple and it's basically
let's build on a recognition the process
realities just to review we're data
intensive we're moving forward with
language modeling and Analysis construed
very broadly and that we recognize the
primary role of tooling and automation
Microsoft has this phrase managed code
and the reality is okay I'm an emac user
I've been using emac since before there
was emac you know nonetheless if you
really want to build real systems you're
probably not using emx you're probably
working in an environment with IDE and
team support and various other and that
helps us manage and and deal with all
that data second is uh that we have a
recognition of the emerging
product
the role of architectures and apis the
incredible complexity and power
therefore of these Frameworks that let
half a million apps go into the app
store for iOS and half a million apps go
in the app store for Android and I'm
sure my numbers are low okay and the
importance of scaling through
composition because everything connects
to
everything okay all right so also a
recognition that with respect to our
Assurance techniques taking a semantic
bias is really the right thing to to be
doing we're doing really great work with
testing and inspection but you know what
we can build tools to make inspection
much more productive right to help
answer questions that come up during
inspections using analyses even simple
analyses and if you use an IDE like
Eclipse it's very easy to get answers to
those kinds of questions that might be
asked and would otherwise be very hard
to answer to recognize the diversity of
those attributes the bad news is there
are lots of them the good news is each
has its own story and we can make
progress on many of them
to think about metrics that are actually
based on
analysis not just counting lines of code
or hours or what have you okay and to
use those metrics to reward Developers
for making progress in developing those
fragmentary specifications and
developing analysis results as well as
developing code and then really
recognizing that the technical challenge
of composition is fundamental and
finally that if we don't think about the
economics we're going nowhere fast and
that was one of the big problems in the
70s and 80s like to talk about Roi if I
ask a developer to write one particle of
annotation at not null then that
developer better get some benefit pretty
much within the hour and it can be a
tiny benefit but it's got to be enough
of a benefit and if it's not you know
something in the development process
it's got to be like an Eminem or
something because that developer Roi is
fundamentally what's going to make this
all work and take off sort of this
diffuse end benefit to the nameless
maintainers from now is not going to go
anywhere I want to add this one
traceability this is the hidden secret I
think I think the great breakthroughs
are going to be related to traceability
connecting all these pieces and labeling
those links and knowing which links are
actually sort of semantic what's the
meaning of the link you know which links
are heuristic enable me to focus
attention to to use all that data and
all those fragmentary specifications so
that when I make a change somewhere in
the system right if I add a component
then that helps me Focus my attention to
quickly get back into a state of harmony
with respect to the fragmentary
specifications and the analysis results
okay so that's the summary now here's a
just a final wacky idea I'm about out of
time here the final wacky idea is and
this came from a the NSF cyber security
conf confence there was a session and
the session I I was asked to chair and I
thought this is a crazy idea building
codes that's a such an old idea but if
you think about a building code the
actual equities that are played out
you've got Architects people who are
going to inhabit the building people are
going to build the building the people
are going to inspect the building
they're all these stakeholders and they
all are in horrendous conflict with each
other and there's a constant pace of
innovation and if you work that out and
look at the process by which building
codes emerge you see actually there's
some possibilities here this is not a
bad metaphor to consider has to be
dithered a little bit but it's not
actually a very bad metaphor to consider
so that's the end of my story I I
appreciate the opportunity to speak I've
got to say one thing about David notkin
who was really an inspiring figure even
when he was a grad student those of you
who were at CMU at the time remember how
inspiring he was then he really had four
characteristics he had a strong Vision
he showed respect for data he showed the
value of working hard to get some data
and then need to analyze it correctly
and he also had respect for semantics
and and really doing the
math right we do great math but we got
to encapsulate and hide that math
awesome as it is for our users because
they don't really enjoy it that much
right and finally a willingness to push
to change the paradigms and I and I
think that we can appropriate these
lessons to this activity I think the
time is right I think we really have an
opportunity to disrupt in a really way
if we think in the right way about our
practices and our tools and our
languages thanks very
much okay so we have time for one
question uh can I have my panelists come
up and sit at the table while we're
answering it yes
Kevin IED to get your response to uh a
proposition uh that computer science is
on a course was systems
engineering you see this most
particularly today that had to be the
one question
respect cyber system yes yes let me
clear this
out affility adaptability
depil
interoperability where we can
comprehensive of the key alties of
complex systems
uh that are so heavily on software so so
that's a really hard question and I
would be disrespecting the panelists if
I tried to offer a full answer but what
I will say is the bottomup attitude is a
really good attitude to take and the
bottomup attitude is figure out what we
can do with the data that we've got what
little tweaks we can make to get some
additional bit of assurance okay and
pick those ilities off fragment by
fragment and I think that's the right
way to go that's incremental progress
for the community okay and we'll see the
rewards in practice and those who
observe those rewards in practice will
reinforce that system okay and that's
really I think the way we've got to go
but the other point about systems
engineering is you got to pay attention
to the actual technical realities the
semantic stuff that exists in the world
of software because it's very different
from the other disciplines that are
integrated into the
systems
okay great thank you for a wonderful
talk so uh next on our agenda is a panel
so the way this panel is going to work
is that each of my panelists were
missing a
panelist oh there you are
sorry um I can count but not pattern
match so uh each of the panelists is
going to get about 5 minutes and I'm
going to hold them to it uh to present
some ideas about their vision for the
future of software engineering in
particular what are the big open
directions and open problems that we
need to be solving and then we're going
to open it up to questions and the
questions will be to them or to anyone
else who have spoken or to anyone else
in general ask big important questions
uh some of them have slides so why don't
we start with David since he is on the
edge
talk from here how do I
Advance a second you can advance
here there you can uh do I get
a thanks um so it's an almost impossible
thing to do is to talk meaningfully
about open problems in five minutes but
take a quick crack here um was I was
thinking about this you know one can
look at at open problems in terms of of
very specific things or very general
things and I'm trying to pick something
here that I think is an emerging Trend
and we can actually see it in many of
the talks that we've heard about heard
today and that is a shift from focus on
development time to
runtime so the problem is today you know
as our systems uh get put out there and
become uh relied upon that we have uh
requirements for high availability and
performance even in the presence of lots
of changes around the system and inside
it uh the environment various kinds of
faults uh different changes in user
needs at different times uh system
upgrades uh human errors and even
maliciousness and through all of that we
would like to do this in a way uh
without costly human intervention and so
this leads um to a natural conclusion
that what we need are systems that um
can be uh um well that that we can begin
to use uh systems and techniques from uh
development time and put them in the
runtime and let me just give some
examples for that uh the the basic idea
here is to migrate many of our
techniques to runtime and automate their
use and we can see lots of examples of
that uh quality assurance for example
which we think of as a a time during
development where we we find bugs and
where we determine uh whether the system
has the properties we want uh can be
done in terms of runtime Diagnostics and
testing um architecture manifests itself
in many ways at runtime time through for
example runtime um architecture-based
self- adaptation or techniques for
actually adjusting qualities of service
uh dynamically making tradeoffs that
would otherwise be fixed at at
architecture
time analysis uh things like runtime
model checking and simulation um and
requirements where you establish new
goals at runtime and work them out as
sort of system changes we can see
there's actually examples of research in
all those areas going on but I think
it's important to real iiz that this is
a big shift in the way we think about
software engineering and as we I will
skip over my examples um of this because
we don't have time um that in general
one compose a whole family of
interesting re research open problems
which says take your favorite uh design
time technique and ask yourself how
could we deploy this in a runtime
setting um you'll find that when you do
that there's typically um a reasonable
idea behind it but in in fact there are
some fundamental changes you have to
make in order to be able to deal with
the real-time nature of decision making
uh with some certain kinds of
uncertainty and so on um so um but once
you've done that then there's a lot of
other problems that arise for example
how do you have Assurance about these
things that are happening at runtime and
actually changing the system um how do
you actually improve the adaptations
that are going on and the the
performance of the things that you've
put into the runtime uh mixed initiative
control we heard today uh in a couple of
the talks about uh approaching the user
and being able to work them into the
system and that introduces a kind of of
of non-determinism into the whole
problem that makes it really
tricky um how do we design our system so
that they have the right control
services for the adaptations we want to
make proactivity how do we look forward
in terms of the adaptations instead of
just reacting to problems but actually
um anticipate what they will be and fix
them and in general being able to take
control systems uh ideas that have been
around for years and years and be able
to pose those in the context of software
based systems where you no longer have
differential equations to help you out
here so overall uh the general point I
want to make is simply that you know
there's a very large class of very
interesting open problems um hiding
under this whole uh business that we're
moving towards where we take uh static
uh development time techniques and move
them into the runtime
just one SL can you just and let me just
stand over there that's exactly what I'm
doing thank
you all right I just have one how do I
turn this on hello okay all right I just
have the one slide and as you can see it
doesn't it's really doesn't really say
much of anything well it turns out what
I'm going to say is more or less what
David said in a very but a somewhat
different way uh my slide shows my
affiliation and my lab's logo the
important thing about the logo is you
know it says we enable and it's really
not just my lab but it's a software
engineering community and also the
programming language is community what
we enable is software that everything
about software that all other software
related communities build upon and
unfortunately we're sort of always
thinking in terms of building we're
focusing on building we're focusing on
design time we're focusing on devel
velopment time and basically the same
thing David said is I think the thing
that we need to do is not be such an
idealist that we're going to get it
right the first time and get it out into
the environment and you know deploy
correctly but be more like I don't know
some of the people I've met we have in
my department in Colombia now some
people in operating systems some people
in security who are doing what looks to
me exactly like software engineering
except they're doing it at runtime
they're doing it in the deployment
environment and I think we need to do
that too in fact the reason they're
doing this cuz we didn't do it cuz we
didn't get it right and we're not we're
never going to get right no matter how
much fun we make software software
engineering uh no matter you know how
much context the software developer has
um you know matter how much science we
bring to bear on it we will never be
able to prevent all bugs all
vulnerabilities and so forth we'll never
get it right the you know the first time
so we have there will always be bugs and
we have to become pragmatists and be
able to you know find them at runtime
and deal with them at runtime and that's
all I had to say thank
you and who do I pass
to okay no no slides in a in a novelty
for uh this technical discipline you're
just going to listen not watch uh oh I
do have a slide all right it's got my
affiliation um I uh I want to make two
points uh one about an engineering
discipline for software and one about
software research
methods um I really want to uh not
respond to the individual talks today so
much as go back and touch base with the
idea that if we're going to call it
software engineering we ought to take
seriously the proposition that we're
striving to build an engineering
discipline um so to touch base with that
idea um let's look at the definition of
engineering there there are many but
they boil down to this that engineering
is an activity about creating
costeffective
solutions to practical
Problems by applying systematic codified
knowledge to building things in the
service of mankind and definitions of
engineering pretty much have those
Clauses in them now those practical
problems are situated in the
world um in the World At Large there are
vastly more people who are not highly
trained Computing professionals who are
not only using computing but who are
tailoring Computing to their own
needs and we are doing a dreadfully bad
job of giving them systems that they can
understand and that they can manipulate
either to their satisfaction or or
without risk of safety to the public so
Lori showed us some examples from
medical processes um where they can take
ideas from software engineering into an
application domain and in terms of that
application domain make real
progress um but we have a desperate need
to make our Technologies comprehensible
accessible manageable by people who are
not like ourselves and I want to call
that out as the huge research Challenge
and research
opportunity uh another Clause of that
definition is about systematic codified
knowledge well Mike asked where' Mike go
uh Mike asked when are we going to take
away
control um and my answer is it's high
time to take away control of some of the
details that don't matter that much and
I remember the uh the conversion uh the
Great Leap from Assembly Language to
higher level languages in around 1960
the early 1960s maybe up to 1970 and one
of the one of the one of the big
objections was if you only give me three
Loop structures I won't be able to write
all the loops that I've got now and you
know it turns out that for the most part
that's okay so so gratuitous variability
uh and its Associated cost in
maintenance uh lead me to say yeah we
should start taking away
control um so systematic cified
knowledge in the case of engineering
means engineering handbooks uh means
building codes Bill talked about
building
codes um this is uh this is about taking
the things that we know that work in the
routine cases and getting them organized
so that we can just go on about our
business and worry about the hard
stuff uh we could do a better job of
that Prem said that exact models may not
work so we all have an urge for
well-founded theories for exact analysis
for complete proofs of the entire
specification and at scale in the real
world in Practical problems that's not
practical one of the ways that we've
dealt with that is with uh empirical
statistical models but they don't lend
themselves that well to explanations if
you look at the engineering World they
really like linear models not all the
phenomena they Des cribe or linear but
linear models are mathematically
tractable uh and they're good enough in
most cases um in addition we don't need
to prove everything uh what we need to
do is to
show as Alex was saying that we're
getting the right outcomes or we're
detecting that we're not getting the
right outcomes but without worrying
about all the details of the ancillary
activities of the systems that don't
actually matter that
much um so here again um so as with as
with making Computing accessible to real
people we need better abstractions that
work for them we need better
abstractions um about systematic
codified knowledge that that work for
Designing and developing systems um I
say again what I said earlier that I
think we need to to break the bonds that
tie us so strongly to the code uh and
think about the systems as a whole bill
talked about Supply chains that's one
way of doing that
um so we're engineering software systems
we need to take a systems View and we
need to find abstractions that will let
us work at the system level for that
purpose so with respect to an
engineering discipline for software um I
think we need to we have lots of
opportunities uh to focus on finding uh
abstractions that work for us that work
at a high level uh and that make our
systems comprehensible not just by us
but by other
people uh now this is fuse not fuse
research but but we are here mostly
researchers and I want to take a minute
to talk about opportunities in research
methods so lri said Lori talked about
methodologically defensible research
plans and we had a short exchange this
morning um about the state of research
in software engineering and as as I said
then uh I think we have progressed in
the last decade uh principally by
understanding a handful of particular
research approaches uh the most
conspicuously being uh being empirical
methods um but that doesn't exhaust the
needs of the research Community we have
a lot of different kinds of of problems
that we solve we use a wide variety of
different research approaches from
formal mathematics uh through
statistical empirical work through human
uh investigations through through
qualitative design and methods um and so
to have a research methodology that
works you need to be able to identify a
matched
set U of A Research claim of the
techniques you're using to investigate
that claim and produce a result and of
the evidence in the
validation uh and I I emphasize a
matched set because some kinds of
validation work for some kinds of claims
I repeatedly have discussions with PhD
students in which they say my claim is
da da da all da da da da da and I'm
going to do it with an empirical
analysis well sorry if you want the
unversal quantifier in the claim you're
going to have to do something formal in
the method um so we need to understand
better what constitutes a matched set of
claims and methods and
validations uh so that we as researchers
and that we as reviewers and that we as
members of program committees can can
generate methodologically defensible
research
strategies um much remains to be done in
that area though I think we are making
progress um so there's two points one
about an engineering discipline of
software we and what about research
methods for getting
there so uh I'm the virtual Tom Ball Tom
had to leave early and he asked me to
stand in for him um I have two points to
make about sort of promising directions
for software engineering one of which is
the point that Tom was planning to make
which I'm wholeheartedly in agreement
with and the other one is uh my own
point which I don't know whether Tom
agrees with or not but uh we'll assume
he does um the first one which is the
point Tom was planning to make is that
there's a a extremely promising
opportunity for the research this
community does to take advantage of
cloud the cloud um and I can sort of uh
talk to that very directly because about
a year and a half ago Galen hunt and I
started a project inside Microsoft
called Cloud build which was an attempt
to get developers to stop building
software on the desktop machine mov to a
cluster of machines in the cloud you
know many of you know Google already has
this they're very successful with this
um it's a great idea um you know
obviously there's lots of things that
could be done in the research Community
um there are two things I have to say
about it one of which is that something
happened with this uh idea that I've
never seen happen before inside
Microsoft uh we wrote a white paper we
circulated it around and developers from
the rest of the company were so excited
they volunteered to come over and help
Us in research to build this usually
it's the other way around we're going
over and begging them to look at
something that we've done we had a white
paper and they were volunteering to
write code um there's a huge opportunity
here to improve developers lives by
basically accelerating the process of
building software um that's only the tip
of the iceberg though um the reason that
I was particularly excited about it is
that once you've done that you have all
of the artifacts and the beginning of
the tools living in the cloud and a lot
of good things come from that one of
which is that other parts of the
software life cycle can be moved onto
this platform and done in parallel at
very large scale testing is the obvious
thing to move next um tools are another
thing that benefits from this and so why
is this important well one thing is that
all of a sudden you can start sharing
artifacts of all of these processes at a
very fine grin so when I build something
and Bill comes along and builds
something and he's changed one file he
could take all of the binaries that I
had with the exception of a couple of
them and just reuse them so instead of
running the compiler again and doing
redundant computation we can just
accelerate the build process now for
building you know that has large
advantages but imagine how much it has
for advantages in other parts of the
process which are even more expensive
testing is more expensive than building
in general static analysis if you're
doing it across the entire program is
even more expensive you can reuse large
parts of these analyses or these builds
or these tests across users second thing
is that you've all of a sudden got
everybody running on a common platform
and all of the things that are important
in terms of developing software with a
community and a process are a lot easier
to do if the software is not living on
machines and people's desks in their
offices that are sometimes turned off
and so forth you can see across an
entire project which is why lots of
people in the company are extremely
excited about this Prospect uh will from
schy who many of you know has actually
gone off and built a t uh a team outside
of research to build this idea out so
that's the sort of one interesting
Direction I recommend to this community
the second thing which I I'll say is
that I heard a lot of talks today about
sort of going and building tools for
helping people build software the way we
already have built software um I have to
say that there's another way way to look
at this which is that we need to teach
people how to build software better than
the way we build it now and not go and
sort of try to patch up the software
that we have and try to find the bugs in
it but instead try to help people write
software that has fewer bugs or that is
intrinsically more secure um give you a
concrete example a few years ago Gallen
hunt and I built an operating system
called Singularity it was had two sort
of very important features for this
community one of which is entirely
written in a high level language C so
buffer overruns that type of attack just
totally prevented by the type system and
the memory safety in in the language
second thing is that we thought about
the architecture that was made possible
by having safe languages and we built
something that was far more contained
and isolated than today's systems so
everything lived in its own process all
the way down to the device driver level
processes only communicated across
channels which are effectively
capabilities and so we had an operating
system system that was fundamentally
more robust than what you have now that
is the kind of thing that actually
changes the way people look at software
and build software is it perfect no of
course it's not perfect we had bugs we
knew that but it changes the way people
it just sort of starts people at a
higher level than they were before when
they're writing in C or something like
that and so in particular when I look at
something like the mobile space where we
had this Clean Slate we didn't have any
backward compatibility and I said all
these people writing in the same old
languages using the same Frameworks that
we had P ported over and having the same
bugs the same attacks the same problems
I'm very discouraged that you know
various communities including this
community didn't say let's go let's do
it better let's learn from the mistakes
let's try to produce software that's
just fundamentally better by Design so
that's what I thank
you
okay so I would now like to open it up
to questions and I'll let the panel self
uh decide who's going to answer more
question
the
the soft engineering
problems
else well I'll take on a little piece of
it um which is the notion that we have
of of um checking in
correctness
um there's been an evolution from my
program has a specification and it is
correct which is applicable to things
that are small enough to be practical uh
to be tractable um and as the problems
get bigger and as they get particularly
as they get embedded in physical systems
where the physical systems don't
themselves have repeatable Behavior um
we need to adapt um our understanding of
what constitutes an acceptable program
uh from the theoretical model of correct
to the the model of it does what I need
to do right now and that that involves
having criteria that reflect the context
of the problem as well as the the system
that's that's uh solving the problem um
it involves um having um approximate
models that are mathematically tractable
that you understand may not be exact but
but they're good enough for practical
purposes I think there's a lot of
opportunity in that
Arena yeah one thing I I would like to
say with sort of related to the same
idea and this is sort of getting at what
I was getting before is that you know
we're not going to get everything
correct we're not even going to know
what is correct I mean that was I think
your your point that once we get to yeah
cyber physical systems very details what
especially in The Fringe details oh yeah
yeah we're not we're never going to have
complete specifications for a lot of you
know a lot of these very complex systems
particularly like Mary mentioned in
cyber physical Arena and so forth and so
we have to you know deal with the
reality and that was what I was getting
out respect to some of my you know
colleagues in operating system security
they deal with the reality all the time
that there will be a Breakin you know
there will be a system crash you know
and do they have to figure out how are
they going to work around it how are
they going to deal with it in real time
when it really happens and I'd like to
see more of you know our community
working in that area and of applying
software engineering kinds of mechanisms
to what really happens at real time at
deployment and then you know use it for
feedback use it to go back to the
development lab and make patches you
know and changes and so forth rather
than just you know a patch on the Fly
and then forget about it but um you know
we have to deal with the reality of of
things going
on um I was going to mention cyber
physical systems also because I think uh
having started to work at in this area
one of the problems is you you run into
uh uh system development efforts that
involve totally different communities
with completely different perspectives
on what it means to go about designing a
system and yet they all have to somehow
come together um so reconciling physical
models or control simulation models with
uh software protocol models it's not
clear at all how to do that um but I
think it's something we really need to
address and somehow I don't see much of
that going on here in terms of of
broadening our our own ideas of how to
uh reconcile the kind of things we know
well with the things that they do
Wells
are with each
other if you
wantu
st no I mean your point is well taken is
that that it's complicated when you
bring out a new let's say device like a
mobile phone and you decide you want
people to program it on it um but the
larger picture point I think is that
there were no good alternative models
developed by the academic community that
would have said if a company let's say
apple had wanted to do better than what
they did what would they have done you
know were there well-worked out models
that had been studied over many years
that seemed to offer promise that they
would have been considering whether they
wanted to take the risk in that space or
not and I would argue that there weren't
those models and so there was an obvious
thing to do which was to continue what
you knew how to do and use the tools
that you already had and that's lower
costs but there was nothing to balance
it against it and that I think is the
unfortunate part and that's what I think
academic researchers can particularly
bring to the table is the ability to
look at these problems
uh further out in a context that's not
as tied to product deadlines as U people
and companies
are's
Comal science retion and paradig science
and we should always be using principles
when even in the Paradigm we may not
have the cified body of book look up
situations actually if you to react that
can I something
to
okay so I wanted to react
about
moving more of our
activities design to run way saying that
is whenever you have a static analysis
why are you doing that analysis
statically should be doing it
dynamically instead or as well and I
think that makes a lot of sense I don't
think that I think that in the future
all successful Dynamic all successful
analyses are going to have to have
components of both because when you look
at Dynamic loading and uh met
and MultiLing systems it's going be very
to analyze sta but I wanted to bring up
two concerns about this that maybe
anyone on the panel can react to the
first is that I think we have to
recognize that whenever you move an
analysis from sta time to Dynamic time
then you are abandoning the guarantees
and understanding system I never said
move it I said do both okay I I never
intended to say stop doing the things
we're doing now but I was saying we
addition need to do these other things
because you know we're fa we're failing
what we're doing now is not sufficient
okay and so we need to look at doing
something else I agree with that well I
I don't quite agree with that um point
because U if you take uh for example uh
systems that produce U an Adaptive layer
that attempts to to react to problems in
the system in a control systems kind of
way way through monitoring and then re
um actuation um you can analyze the
control uh phenomena and the the
programs that are in that um even though
they're running at runtime so many of
the adaptation techniques that are being
used there can be guaranteed at uh to do
the right thing at run time so I'm not
sure we're abandoning uh completeness or
or Assurance
there like one very particular type of
software we think about set of that's a
small part of it the fact that you can
get some kind of guarantee there even
even though you're doing rtime
monitoring seems
value
app or
atast well for sure you don't want only
do that I agree with that right so so
the one point was a concern you know
you're gaining tremendous Precision but
you're losing these guarantees the other
thing is that I would think we should
also be thinking about going the
opposite direction whenever you're doing
an analysis dynamically right now
whether it's being done by the runtime
system or by a check that the programmer
is doing or or uh by higher level
monitoring system we should be asking
ourselves why aren't you doing that
statically that is in addition to taking
everything we're doing now statically
and trying to do it dynamically as well
we should be taking everything that
we're doing dynamically and try to do
them statically as well because they'll
be more conservative they'll be less
precise and they'll give us C
in terms of behavior improving the
understanding and structure of our
systems and so I think we really need to
see that that sharing going both
directions I want to respond to that
part of my argument was not just we
should do things dynamically but we
should also do things in the deployment
environment which means with the real
users with the real data that they are
really working with and yes that can
feed back to you know static analyses
but the you know what we have to deal
with right there is the actual
dynamism running the static checks and
so forth in their environment may not
really make sense I mean it makes sense
to use the same environment but the
overhead and so forth may may be uh um
inappropriate in fact that's something
to work on that's another topic to work
on is you know what can we do to make it
plausible to run those static checks in
their environments in real time while
they're doing
things this should not be just about
static and dynamic analysis of code um
if if you evaluate a piece of code in
isolation uh then in order to make
guarantees you have to make guarantees
that are applicable to all the contexts
of
execution um and so some guarantees or
some analyses ought to be done in
context uh because the context
establishes the properties that actually
matter in that particular setting and by
focusing on those rather than having to
uh to to to to validate all the
properties you'll you'll focus better
and and save
energy so it's not it's not just static
Dynamic versus code but but there's the
the question of the the context and and
beyond that um there are design
techniques that you can use that will
assure things um on down the line so so
let's not just cast this as static
versus analysis there are many more
points that at which the analyses can be
done and
so all the analyses should be done as
early as possible but no
earlier um since JavaScript came up
several times today and it it relates to
this I think I I'd like to sort of also
drag into the context the whole question
of why this vast movement has occurred
from languages that have you know
well-known type systems that are
checkable at least partially statically
to these Dynamic languages like
JavaScript which are extremely difficult
to check um and you know I think the
challenge there is that developers find
something in these languages whether
it's small startup cost or greater
productivity that they don't find in the
other languages and that to me is a
challenge that's worth going back and
reinvestigating which is you know what
makes these languages so attractive that
people are willing to give up things
that I think are very very valuable like
check uh type checking as someone who's
written you know tens of thousands of
lines of list code you know I pined for
something that would actually give me a
guarantee about that I wasn't going to
have you know an integer added to a
string um so you know again this is
something that is very difficult to do
if you're in the middle of developing
something commercially but it's this is
the community that should be answering
this question um and I would love to
sort of see this Dynamics EC static
expanded Beyond just the question of
when these analyses happen to why people
want them to happen that way and what
advantages are they getting from
deferring things until runtime oh could
I add one thing um I got trapped into uh
the Assumption of your question um which
is the thing that should be analyzed is
the code um these large systems are
chalk full of things other than the code
uh they're full of U of models 3D models
of of things to be displayed they're
full of data um and a lot of the uh
integration problems that you run into
are actually ontology mismatches in the
in the data structures themselves um so
I want to make a short appeal for
extending this this uh contemplation of
uh of analysis and validation uh to all
that other stuff in the system besides
the code uh especially the
data all right so you're talking a lot
about codifying
engineering you're talking a lot about
codifying engineering and I think as
software engineer it's our duty to take
one step further than what Engineers did
before and have that Cod F I mean our
knowledge should be machine readable
such that it is usable by our software
so if we look at current software
engineering we produce textual documents
all over the place it's full of
terminology it's full of words these
words have special meanings in their
context and their domains our machines
are really poor at dealing with these
things and a lot of it has to do with
their lack of confidence so be nice not
only with the codification of our
engineering that we also have machine
that the machines can understand the
context of these Tex I was wondering if
the panel has any ideas related to this
topic of cont
Mach so uh since I have the microphone
I'll start uh
I don't want to criticize the
organization of this this day but it
seems to me that the discussion here has
left out what I consider to be the most
important part of software engineering
and software development which is the
people that you know the the problem
with what you suggest is that if we make
things less readable by people and more
readable by machines then we exacerbate
a already difficult problem which is
that a lot of and a lot of problems in
software development are caused by lack
of understanding and lack of interaction
among the people who are doing the
development in rather large teams of
people and so you know it's not an it's
not an easy choice to say just make
things more formal because at the same
time you make them less
readable there's online and there's
online um the classic engineering
handbooks you know I think about Perry's
Handbook of of chemical engineering
which is nine by 12 by about 4 in thick
and printed in twoo type on Bible paper
um this this has the body of knowledge
uh but it gets reissued about once every
10 or 15 years this isn't good enough
for us um I'm in favor of having that
kind of organized systematic reference
knowledge um online because that's the
way we get to information these days um
but that's online for Access by people
um and Jim was suggesting that you might
have metant online for Access by
automated U analyzers um if that works
out that's nice but I think getting it
accessible to people is most
important um but
um there was a third case that has just
slipped my mind
um offline
offline
Joe did you still have a
comu
c
so is is is this the same I think it was
Mary comment about when we mve to high
level languages people couldn't write
Loops in a billion different ways and
maybe that maybe that wasn't maybe that
wasn't such a bad thing
either
I'm sure I'm sure there were interesting
Loops that people wrote before
weu a lot
of right so I'd like to something this
isn't specifically scripting languages
but IT addresses the the issue that's
that's sort of come up several times
here about you know these the modern
high level languages with all kinds of
you know checks built in and so forth so
you can't you simply can't make a lot of
same kinds of mistakes and you know I've
been hearing this for a long time and I
remember you know you know about the
time I finished my PhD we had this
wonderful language called Ada you know
and then eventually yeah we had Java and
we you know we had this that the other
thing but so much code out there is
still written in C and 20 years from now
will still be written in C that's my you
know a lot of this about prescription
but that's my prediction okay and it
will still have the same bugs it's had
you know for the last 40 years or
whatever and I don't think that's going
to change in scripting languages the new
code written in scripting language will
often have a lot of the same bugs but
you know maybe different ones but we're
still going to have that same old
problem with that old C code and you
know that isn't isn't really going
away so I I think uh I I like a language
because I can fiddle around in it is
kind of self-indulgent because it it um
um it doesn't respect the implications
of having idiosyncratic code that's
going to be there six days six weeks six
months or six years from now for
somebody else to maintain on the other
hand uh maybe
maybe not um on on the other hand there
there are languages that are not
full-blown strongly typed programming
languages which sometimes are too
strongly typed for their own good I
would add um but but that capture the
abstractions of a particular domain so
there are there are a number of domain
specific languages that have um have
have crafted uh notations sometimes
graphical notations for particular
problem domains that bring the level of
discourse closer to the uh the problem
domain and to the the experts in the
problem domain and that provide fewer
opportunities for gratuitous fiddling
around that leads to errors and and
those I think we should give a lot of
credit
for um yeah indeed uh I've been looking
at a a few domains that you could think
of generally as sort of the escience
kinds of domains where people are uh
trying to compose fairly interesting
computational systems analytics and so
on and when you look at the the things
they have to write it's it's really
awful these horrible scripts and glue
code and and things that that are almost
impossible to debug or to maintain or to
um to even reuse um and although
programmers might really want to have
that kind of flexibility it seems like
most of the world the the the 90% that
Mary mentioned in terms of end users who
are are actually having to to take
advantage of computation for their
profession uh not because they're
professional programmers um they
actually really would rather work in a
much more constrained world of of either
domain specific languages or tools that
really guide them towards uh Simple
Solutions to what they want to do with
the analytics that actually make sense
to them um in their
field
that I'm sure I'm sure sure the number
is true and I think the answer you you
said it which is that every browser in
existence supports JavaScript and you
can do things in it in terms of building
user interfaces that you can't do in
HTML and CSS and so everybody does
it some of
these
use
dnamic
itic
so a lot of JavaScript is also generated
as the assembly code out of tools so um
Steve lco talked the other day about
typescript which is Microsoft's typed
subset of JavaScript which generates
fairly unexciting JavaScript
code
well based not on looking at any of the
JavaScript but based on looking at a lot
of the websites in question um it seems
to me that a great deal of that code is
really doing State transitions um about
the web page you do this and the page
transforms in the following way and
JavaScript seems to me like a really
poor substitute for an actual State
transition description language and um
perhaps describing those web pages in
something that let you think about the
states and the state transitions rather
than something that can be mapped back
to them if you decompile it would be a
um a step
forward
let's do one question last question this
is I'm Julius by the way I'm at UBC and
uh I just want to bring this back to all
of software engineering I want to tell
you something I saw once and it goes
back to what Gail was saying about we're
never going to get it right the first
time and um so I went back to visit a
company that I worked for for several
years and uh I walked into the developer
area there finding 30 developers in
cubicles and then there was the wall the
wall was the manager and above the
manager's office on this wall they
printed a huge
banner and the banner said get it right
the first time but there was a little
square of paper tape to the banner right
after the word right get it right little
square white paper kind of you couldn't
really see it far away the first time
and so I asked one of my friends who
still work there I was like why is there
little
on your he said oh well there's a comma
under that square
paper and I just I think that thing is
like it's the funniest and the saddest
thing I've ever
seen it's
so I'd like to abuse my power here and
ask the last question um in several of
the things were mentioned today in
particular in the panel um I heard an
overtone of thinking code at a higher
order thinking about higher level of
fractions something's tically resonated
so the question that I'd like to ask is
do you see a Resurgence of architecture
research in the near or far
future
add so um well there are two two places
where I think architecture um are
particular is particularly important one
is in the runtime setting so we've
always thought about architecture as
something that happens design time and
it's there to assist us in making for
example quality attribute trade-offs but
but imagine that you had a system where
you had some knobs that allowed you to
make those quality attribute trade-offs
at runtime doing on thefly architectural
decision- making for example that's a
very different thing but it requires
models of architecture but a very
different set of mechanisms um so so
that's one example the other one is in
the end user communities I think many of
the people that actually do composition
um in in their in their own professions
are really being more like Architects
than programmers or would like to be
they want to compose pieces and they
want analyses similar to what Architects
want namely performance security privacy
that's what they really want and the
scripts are there just to get them by to
do that so again I think there's another
way of looking at architecture in terms
of raising the level um and and in some
sense making it more domain specific so
that people who are not trained uh
software Engineers can actually use
that certainly one want to go before
those two um I actually think
architecture is incredibly important uh
to getting software right I mean I think
that's sort of a truism but it's one of
these Concepts that many people seem to
come out of school without really
believing and understanding that I mean
I've never had more difficult
discussions at Microsoft with software
developers than discussions about
architecture um you know they just do
not seem to have learned this at some
point in their career the the importance
of getting the architecture correct and
what you could do about it how to talk
about it and I think it's very
unfortunate particularly you know I've
been moving into new areas things like
um cloud computing where a lot of what's
going on is people are trying to Define
find what the effective architectures
are and what you see is this tragedy of
CTO after CTO of these little companies
producing decks talking about well we
did it this way and it didn't work for
these reasons and we did it this way and
it worked until we got 10 times more
customers and then you know and they all
are following down the same set of
architectural steps but nobody is able
to step back and sort of talk about it
as an architectural problem that they're
all trying to solve the same problem by
building scalable uh efficient websites
and you know I think that the the idea
is there and there and they all realize
the sort of importance of it but they
don't have the vocabulary or the
abstractions to talk about it and I
think that's really too bad because you
know particularly in a new area you get
to see architecture being invented and
people thrashing around trying to
understand what it is they just
did I I resonate with your statement
that that a lot of the people you talk
to don't have a sense um of what their
architecture is um I think a lot of this
is a result of the development tools
that
implicitly um lock you into some
particular architecture um and then you
wind up defaulting into that
architecture because that's the tool
that everybody uses rather than actually
thinking about what would be a better
choice
yeah okay and on that note I will
transition to our closing s let's thank
the
panelists if I can ask my co-organizers
to come
up so we would like to conclude this by
um a certain call to action we talked we
spent all day today talking about uh
different kinds of problems different
kind kinds of progress that has been
made in various groups and so let me
just start out by uh summarizing some of
the big ideas and big problems we've
come up
with the first problem
is what's in my pocket um so we talked
about uh several of the speakers talked
about how to use humans better in our
research and in software systems so uh
there were three different areas which
were touched one is how to understand
developers better and how to build tools
that work better with the
developers uh another point that was
touched on was understanding the users
and being able to verify that what the
users are doing is actually what you
expect them to do and what the system
expects them to do um and then finally
there was uh some work on using humans
as tools as part of the software systems
to actually either prove something about
the software system or Advanced the
software system in some way so all of
the some of these are not necessarily
new ideas but there's new problems that
have been identified in those areas but
lots of things with humans that's
something to walk away with uh another
thing we talked about today is software
quality so people have talked about
security and doing that from a very
scientific point of view how do you
ensure security happens uh we've talked
about Assurance Assurance of large
systems Assurance is hard Assurance is
we don't know how to do Assurance for uh
any kind of a complex system so lots of
open problems there uh we talked about
doing outside sorry outside the box
analyses different kinds of analyses
things again that use humans things that
blend different kinds of analyses that
already exist out there in order to be
able to prove or verify different things
about your system that were possible
before um and we talked about improving
the quality of the system in an
automatic Way by using variant
generating automatically lots of
versions of your system and trying to be
able to improve something about your
system that
way okay the third Point here is uh
there was quite a few things with code
Generation Um so PowerPoint decided to
create a variant so um with code
generation we talked about using Code
structure and the repetitiveness of code
in order to automatically be able to
generate program or be able to fix
existing programs and we again also
talked about using variants to improve
the system quality so mutating the
programs automatically to uh create a
system that's better than the original
and then the final point is there were
several application areas that were
brought up there was Healthcare and I
actually expected Healthcare to be a a
really big topic of discussion during
the panel it didn't happen to come up
but there's so many different problems
in healthcare uh from things that Lori
talked about on trying to understand how
humans interacting the healthcare system
to things like uh we want to build
systems for the healthcare uh for
healthare system to use uh we don't have
electronic health records still it is
beyond me why we still don't have
electronic health records as far as I
can tell all the technology is there so
what's missing why haven't we done that
so lots and lots of problems in the
healthcare domain uh we talked a little
about elections domain we've talked
about the new problems that are brought
on by multic corn by cloud computing uh
and we also talked about user interface
faes and how those need to change pretty
dramatically in order to achieve some of
the big goals that we have so these are
some of the um big areas big questions
we've identified today now this is a
one-day Symposium this is not intended
to be a complete list of all the big
problems and all the big advances that
will happen in software engineering in
the next say decade uh it's a subset
it's representative of the people who
spoke today and there's certainly other
problems but I'd like to take this
opportunity to encourage the students to
think about some of these problems don't
limit yourself to these but think about
these think about what you can do in
some of these problems and some of these
questions in your next four or five
years as you're getting your PhD to want
some of you um not because you're very
fast but because you're almost
done uh and uh and see if you can get us
closer to the Future because it's going
to be you doing all the work it's not
going to be old gers like me uh would
you I can't say that yet no okay
sorry um okay I'll do
I'll okay now that I've been put in my
place would you guys like to add
anything
so uh so I think there were a in
addition this is a really nice summary
of what we talked about I think one
other cross cutting theme that I heard
was trying to think about costs so all
of engineering is about balancing costs
and we can think of these in those terms
too for instance for people um should
people be doing the work work should
tools be doing the work uh how should
that be balanced uh in terms of quality
what uh what are you willing to pay uh
in terms of you know the the programming
language we talked about you know uh are
you willing to pay more upfront in order
to pay less later or the opposite and
which one of those makes sense trying to
I mean what we want to do is to not make
random choices we want to make
disciplined choices about these and I
think that's one of the biggest
challenges we have I think the the issue
of how to use people is incredibly
important because what makes our
discipline so difficult is that rather
than if we were analyzing say a
mechanical system we have nonideal
components nonlinear components in our
system they're called people and if only
we didn't have to deal with those our
field would be much easier uh I mean we
get all of the difficult mathematical
challenges and we get all the different
psychological challenges and we're
trying to balance the costs of those and
blend those together I think that's what
makes our field one of the most exciting
in which anyone can work and gives it
tremendous
um uh tremendous uh potential to affect
the world another thing that I saw that
I wanted to bring out is uh trying to
think about problems in a different way
or about different problems so what we
what I heard from people I heard people
saying is we don't just want to think
about what are the old problems and how
can we solve those a little bit better
what we want to do is to cut the gordian
KN of complexity say here's a completely
different way of achieving what your
real goal is or what your real goal
ought to be so don't just think think
here's something that people are doing
diff uh doing in a non-optimal way or
slowly can I help them do it faster
think about how can they help them to do
something completely different because
that's how you're going to disrupt the
current processes of software
engineering and make them much more
effective in the
future uh so i' you know I've really
enjoyed hearing all of those ideas and
many more that can really inspire all of
us right so it's lovely to have the last
word here um thank you very much Yuri
for the what and uh you Mike and also
the why so I'll do a little bit about
the The Who and the where um the who of
course is you uh you're the people who
going to have to take this out and do
something about it and once again I'd
just like to say how delighted we are
now everybody is that that we have such
a great turnout here where are you going
to do it and when so there are various
ways the one is do it with in
collaboration
and uh we've heard on and off throughout
the whole day that if you're going to
tackle the big problems you have to do
it in teams and some of those teams
definitely need to include places
outside the institution you're at so
team up team up with other universities
or industrial um institutions if you can
do that so some of the examples that you
can use for that are the sea awards that
Microsoft research offers and they'll be
coming out again in October keep a watch
for those uh we'll try and notify all of
you if you don't mind us using your
email addresses for that
notification and also um ixie has a
future of software engineering Workshop
doesn't it a track yes yeah a track a
full track uh upcoming so that's another
another thing uh to follow up on that
you can look for uh for your research
actually to publish it and we to talk a
little bit about publishing research
that's in the long term in the immediate
term like in the next 5 minutes um I
think that we can continue this
discussion and there's no better way
than continuing it over a good glass of
Northwest wine and uh our man over there
in the tie dye shirt Chris has arrived
in time and he'll be directing you all
uh in a nice little stroll over to
building 99 where everything is ready
and set up and please um enjoy
yourselves this evening can we make sure
that those of you with special eating
needs go to the front of the queue for
the food once the food is out and uh
have a wonderful time tonight and thank
you
again